[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of alexa and friends my name is
jeff blankenberg uh and as we do every
week we have an interesting conversation
with someone from the world of alexa
today i have pradeep natarajan joining
us pradeep thank you so much for being
here
thank you thank you for having me
homework certainly so one of the things
that we do at the beginning of these
interviews to get to know the person a
little bit is we we ask a couple of
silly questions and so one of the first
questions that i like to start with uh
relates to super powers um if you've
seen any of the marvel movies or dc
movies that have been out recently
you're probably familiar with the
concept of super powers
but i'm always interested to know from
our guests
if you could pick a specific superpower
for yourself not a superhero but just
one individual power
uh what is something that you might
choose for yourself
yeah um i actually might have a very
relevant to my life answer to this oh
great um
i don't know if you have watched uh
popeye the sailor
yeah
cartoons when you were young of course
um
so you know uh this is a person who gets
uh tired uh when physical challenges
come his way
and then uh you know he he eats spinach
right now which is quite healthy as well
yeah and then he gets re-energized right
away
so um that's a superpower i would like
uh because you know as you can see i'm
getting a little older um and i recently
started playing tennis again after
nearly a decade and realized that i'm
much
i tire much easier than before so
uh that's a startup uh you know that's a
superpower i would love to have i i like
that uh it's very close to home i i have
that same feeling
where you know if i didn't have so much
to do during the day and i couldn't just
power through with caffeine
uh i think i would probably be ready for
a nap about two o'clock every day so i i
fully understand what you're saying
yeah
yeah
uh well that's a good one all right so
so your superpower would be
the ability to
and i don't know if you're specifically
saying that you love to eat spinach or
want to eat spinach on a regular basis
but the idea that you you would be able
to eat something simply and then just
have all sorts of energy and strength
and power right
yeah basically
energize yourself quickly
by eating something
you know not too bad for you in the long
run right uh i think that's perfect all
right this this second question is uh
requires a little bit of a story and uh
just just stick with me it's gonna sound
outlandish but it's it's a fun question
so uh i want you to imagine you're
walking through a large city
and uh where you need to get is one
block over from where you are today and
if you imagine a large city you huge
city blocks that you have to walk around
um do you notice that there is a very
convenient well-lit alley that leads you
directly where you need to go
it's not a path you would normally take
but for today it looks like a good
opportunity
so you decide to head down this alley
and as you get about halfway down the
alleyway
in front of you emerges a giant
horse-sized duck like a really really
large duck
and he doesn't look terribly friendly
and so
as you would you turn around and you
head the other direction hoping to get
out of that alley now uh only to find
that that end has been closed by 100
tiny duck-sized horses
so a whole bunch of tiny horses or one
giant duck
the question for you as outlandish as
this question happens to be is which
direction do you think you'd have the
most success getting out and how would
you do it
yeah uh i'm not sure what the right
thing to do here is but uh
personally i'm scared of uh birds with
large beaks
like geese or ducks
so
you know i have been attacked by
canadian geese
some of those unfortunate things that
have happened right
so definitely i'm going to avoid the
duck um
uh so i'm going to run the other way
whatever that other option is
a bunch of tiny horses so it sounds to
me like regardless of how many horses
there are you're going the other way
from a giant duck
got it
got it got it that's that's a good one i
i uh i tend to lean towards the duck i
think i would have a better chance with
the duck but i can see
how certainly having been attacked by
some larger birds
that uh that would probably not be in my
best interest either i understand your
decision completely
yeah
awesome all right so let's get into some
more the serious content and the reason
that you're here um
one of the things that i really like to
share with our audience and one of their
favorite parts of these interviews is to
understand kind of where you came from
so the way i like to explain it is when
you're telling your friends kind of what
your work history looked like or maybe
describing it in an interview
i'd love to hear maybe where you started
where you grew up where you went to
college uh and then kind of the the job
roles that you've had along the way that
got you to where you are today and then
of course we can talk about what it is
you do today and all those things
eventually but i'd love kind of your
your origin story your history
yeah absolutely so um i grew up in india
uh in a
you know mid-sized town
uh in southern india
and then i went to school uh at the
indian institute of technology in
chennai
um
and uh i have been
in computer vision and mission learning
for nearly 20 years now
starting from my undergraduate project
um
but uh in some ways a lot of it also had
to do with serendipitous opportunities
that came my way
um so so to some extent you know uh my
story in computer vision and machine
learning has been
a bit of
uh learning to love what i'm already
doing um rather than you know finding
what i love and then doing it sure so
um
and and you know i i see a lot of uh
recent graduates and stuff who are not
sure what they want to do
and uh you know i just want to say you
know that's perfectly normal
um um you know as you
walk through the doors that are open for
you
and uh dive deeper into what you are
doing uh you will quickly learn that
there are a lot of interesting things
that you can follow up
so in my case you know i got introduced
to cv
um in my junior year in undergrad
uh when one of my seniors he's actually
now at amazon as well
he described his internship the previous
year at an ai lab in bangalore
and suggested trying it out right so you
know i used to like physics in high
school and computer vision at least how
it was done back then
uh looked quite related to physics among
all the computer science areas i was
looking at
and you know i you know i i like the
idea of spending a summer in bangalore
as well
so i started that internship
and then came back to my uh
undergraduate school and uh did my
undergraduate project as well in in a
computer vision related topic
and then uh applied to graduate schools
and again i was actually lucky to get a
phd scholarship at usc at that time
um as the only person with uh just an
undergraduate degree in a lab with
several other folks with lots of
experience and quite seasoned in the
field at that time
um
and uh you know i worked on developing
action recognition systems uh which was
um a lightly explored area at that time
and uh
you know i did my phd in that area
so what is an action recognition system
yeah like uh
uh you know if you are uh walking you
know are you walking or are you running
or are you are you jumping or are you
doing jumping jacks and i'm not making
this up right you know the action
recognition data sets at that time um
actually contained images of someone
standing in front of a
jumping jack
and someone else walking and then our
goal was to build a system that can
distinguish between these two cool right
um
and and and the this looks you know to
someone who is doing computer vision
today all of this looks uh
quite odd but you know this was just 15
20 you know 15 16 years ago uh that's
how we were you know we had a data set
from the basement institute of
technology in israel with 100 samples
and another a data set that someone in
kth released with a thousand samples and
these this was the state of the art at
that time and i was working on
leveraging various sequential machine
learning models to recognize these
actions like you know hidden markov
models and conditional random fields
so um i was sort of moderately
successful i would say uh not um
you know did not light the field on fire
or anything like that uh but but at
least i started with something i knew
nothing about and actually most of the
community also didn't know much about
and created something coherent
during my phd
but the more important thing that
happened to me at that time is
i saw my lab mates doing
very systematic machine learning on
visual data you know they start with low
level feature representation
applied support vector missions and had
very coherent baseline how much they are
improving over the baseline and stuff
and this was surprisingly uncommon in
computer vision in the 2000s
uh compared to you know other machine
learning areas like speech recognition
or nlp
so
i i sort of got experimental discipline
uh during that uh during my phd um and
then the next door that opened was uh
you know i got a chance to work at a
leading speech and language technologies
company in the boston area
um
and and you know
hmms and crs and those kinds of
techniques are very are very very
popular in computer in speech
recognition at that time and even today
to some extent
and because i use the same techniques
for analyzing visual data
uh it connected with the folks there and
uh you know i joined them and started an
exploratory cv initiative uh you know
that turned out to be quite successful
yeah
we started to analyze actual
unstructured web videos you know rather
than these videos collected in
lab conditions and uh
um you know i worked on various projects
where
we participated in international
evaluations and did quite well and i
also got a hands-on feel for data and
modeling problems outside of computer
vision right you know
speech recognition optical character
recognition and such
because that's what most of the folks in
that company were working on and then i
was at amazon for about a year okay um
uh
working on the fire phone building uh
optical character recognition technology
and then i got an opportunity to start a
mission learning group to develop
systematic strategy and trading
strategies at a top h1
um so you know i was looking to do
something different from computer vision
that i spent more than a decade at that
point in time right
and i was looking for a new challenge
and i took it
um
and uh it was it was quite revealing in
that you know the data is different the
nice characteristics are quite extreme
in finance
uh but a lot of the techniques uh i had
previously used in other modalities like
in ensemble methods early and late
fusion wavelets
all of these translated well to that
domain
and i was also exposed to a unique
problem in finance you know which is
called market impact in the industry
which is that you launch a trading model
into the market
your model itself changes the data right
you know you don't see that in other
machine learning domains right you know
just because i put a
pedestrian record detection system
or a asr engine doesn't mean we change
the way we talk
right but in financial markets that
actually happens
and uh so you know reinforcement
learning and some of these online
learning technologies are quite
uh
effective and also crucial in that data
space
um and then you know i spent four years
in finance and then i returned to amazon
again and have been working on
developing technologies to enhance uh
alexa's voice-based interactions with
multi-sensory inputs and also a few
other initiatives involving large
language models and the ability to teach
alexa directly
so that's my origin story uh
uh yeah i i like that all the things
that stood out to me there
uh that i want to get some insight on
the first one was you said you would
initially
um when you were in boston you were
working on
analyzing video uh lab condition style
videos and that you started taking that
to more less lab setting like you know
these are just freely available web
video i think is what you were
describing
did you find that that was a hard
transition between those two or did the
training that you did in those lab
conditions kind of lead to
a strong enough model to allow you to
determine
um the non-lab condition style videos
pretty well
yeah um actually um
what i myself did with the lab style
videos in my phd
were largely
not useful for some of the web videos
but as i mentioned you know i also
learned from others in the community as
well as my own lab mates on more
principled machine learning approaches
and
those methods were also developed on
similar lab condition videos although
there was a slow transitioning happening
during my phd to you know test it out on
more challenging videos like movie
videos and such
and those techniques actually uh
translated pretty well to the web videos
we started analyzing so
um
so so to some extent
um
some of my past work and past knowledge
that i had accumulated did translate
uh but but you know we also had to uh
invent a bit along the way
and in each of those cases you know i i
really relied upon the broader community
rather than
any uh startling insight i was myself
able to uncover yeah yeah that's great
and then the other thing that i wanted
to dig into
was your time uh
at a hedge fund working in on the
financial markets
something that i talk about quite
frequently uh when talking about mba
computing and machine learning is that a
good portion of today's stock market
transactions are actually being done by
models and machine learning today
and one of the things that i haven't
found a specific answer for and i don't
know if you have any insight or even
just an estimation on this
but do you have any idea like what
percentage of trades in the at least in
the us stock market
uh are being made by an algorithm rather
than a human
uh
probably i don't have exact numbers um
but but it's it's a pretty significant
uh
fraction um
i would say
it's it's a very significant fraction
that is uh algorithm-based
um and and you know there are strategies
where you hold an asset for
uh varying uh holding periods right you
know it can can vary from a few minutes
to several weeks
right and each of those problems each of
those settings
introduce their own problems so so the
thing is you know if you're holding for
a short amount of time
the quality of signal you can develop is
better than holding something for a long
amount of time right you know it's much
harder to forecast what will happen 20
days or or a year from now versus what
will happen a minute from now
but the flip side is if you're trading
fast you're incurring a lot of
transaction costs so so you're sort of
juggling these balls right
um and and the longer you hold the
greater the risk that some external
event can uh impact your portfolio so
there are three balls you are basically
struggling right you know what is the uh
quality of your signal what is the risk
you are taking and what are the
transaction costs yeah and that makes it
uh a much harder optimization problem
than if you had only two balls that
you're juggling right you know it's
exactly like juggling you know two balls
you know even people like me can pull it
off but you throw a third ball in it
becomes hard and that's what happens in
uh
automated trading as well interesting
yeah it's just an interesting problem
set for me to as i think about that
specific application of machine learning
yeah just incredibly interesting to me
to think about trades being made on on
microseconds sometimes just trying to
catch one tiny swing and make a few
dollars off of that is interesting
um yeah all right well i will uh i will
get back to some of the things that i
had planned to ask you about i know that
you were recently an organizer for a
workshop on instant level uh recognition
and what was it uh iccv earlier this
month i think uh okay
so
your workshop focus was on artwork and
landmarks and products can you can you
tell us about the workshop that you were
participating in
yeah absolutely and and again uh there
is a recurring theme uh i want to call
out which is that uh
you know i have been in the industry for
a while
but i'm drawing a lot of energy from the
peers and some of the more younger
scientists here at amazon
that i feel quite lucky to be a part of
and in this case you know
one of the scientists
in the team i work with
uh shoes rang
he actually brought do our attention to
an important gap
in uh
in the problem sets that the computer
vision community overall is looking at
which is that you know you have object
recognition and those sorts of things
where there's a lot of data set and a
lot of researchers are focusing on those
kinds of problems right if you want to
distinguish between a painting and a
building right painting is an object
class buildings are an object class and
you're learning a model that can
distinguish between those right there's
a lot of attention
but
a lot of real problems we face
are more at the instance level you know
you're not interested in recognizing a
painting in general but a particular
painting
right
or you take a picture in front of the
eiffel tower or the taj mahal
or
or the meenakshi temple where i'm from
um and you want to recognize that you
are in front of that particular landmark
not necessarily that you are standing
next to a building
right
and and and this this particular problem
is called uh instance level
classification and retrieval
and um
so um uh
you know we decided to participate in
this workshop
and uh create a data set and sort of
communi you know contribute to the
overall computer vision community in
improving our understanding of of this
particular problem
and and and one more interesting thing
in this particular problem is until very
recently deep learning methods were not
the state of the art for ilr right um
recently they have started uh
showing state of the art results
but we wanted to also spark that sort of
investigation in the broader community
on the trade-offs between more
traditional computer vision approaches
versus deep learning methods
when you have very few samples of the
instance you are interested in right um
so
and this builds on uh you know two two
or three more successful
uh editions of this workshop you know uh
there was a
workshop in eccv 2020 and also in cvpr
19 and 18
um
and those two workshops solely focused
on landmarks right uh you're standing in
front of the collation or eiffel tower
and you know can you recognize that that
is the uh ethnographic
um in this edition uh two more domains
were added in addition to the landmarks
one is artwork which i talked about
right um uh we have a
image set of various paintings and can
you build systems to recognize which
painting it is
and from amazon you know we also added a
product database
so
you know again as you would imagine the
product catalogs are pretty large and
several product categories have uh only
one or two images
so can can folks build a system to
recognize these um especially in a
dialogue scenario right
so somebody comes and says you know hey
show me some t-shirts
and then they say you know i'm actually
interested in t-shirts with callers
so the way we framed that problem was we
had a a
an initial image
and then uh
an utterance that is telling basically
the delta that this user is looking for
from what we showed
and a target image and the model we want
to build is
is the target image
consistent with what the original image
was and the delta that the user said
right
here's a t-shirt we are saying the user
asks for a t-shirt with callers and we
have a an
image of a t-shirt with a caller so
that's that's a true
example
if you have a if you have a shirt as the
target that's a false example right
um and you know we are looking to uh
release a large data set you know i
think about two million samples
uh you know which which we shared in the
in the workshop
um and uh you know that that will
represent a significant scale up over uh
existing data sets available for that
particular problem so you know we're all
quite excited you know it's a hard
real relevant problem
um and and we want to uh
uh you know spark some research in that
that threat very much
it seems like there's the potential for
some conflicts in those things as well
because
across those three domains landmarks
products and artwork
um i mean it seems to me that i uh do
you do you find that there was any
conflict for example between a painting
of the eiffel tower or did those those
groupings not overlap they were three
independent
kind of uh
yeah right now there are three
independent data sets uh but as i told
before you know if you want to
distinguish between paintings and and
and a picture of a landmark a picture of
a landmark
um
that's the classic object uh recognition
kind of framework right uh so you know
there are good algorithms that could
actually distinguish between these two
um
um so
even if there are conflicts they are
relatively easier to resolve and then we
look at the instance level
classification problem that's excellent
very good
um all right so one of the other things
that i found as as i was uh looking you
up is that you're the principal
investigator for a team on darpa's
mind's eye product project sorry
um and that's focused on developing
machine capabilities that exist only in
animals like visual intelligence
can you tell me more about this this
sounded really interesting but i wasn't
able to get a ton of um
knowledge about it just in the the
cursory research that i was doing i'd
love to know this sounds incredibly
interesting yeah absolutely so uh you
know at that time um i was actually
leading uh teams in uh
two projects in computer vision uh and
you know this was in 2010 2011 time
frame
um where computer vision was still
largely in the academic or or a small
number of industry labs sort of setting
um rather than something that is not
foundational to large-scale services
um and uh you know darpa mindset which
you called out was one of the projects i
was working on at the time and the other
project i was working on was ir paladin
so with the mindset program
the
uh goal was to develop a capability for
visual intelligence by automating the
ability to learn general and generative
representations of actions so by by
generative what we mean is the model
could actually generate an action rather
than be
rather than a classifier based model
that that could only distinguish between
two actions but doesn't actually
generate the action from its uh from its
representation
so that was uh
one of the projects and there also the
other focus was on the verbs in the
scene rather than the nouns right okay
the aladdin program was looking at a
seemingly different problem you know
which i talked about right uh web video
analysis and classification so can you
look at
all the information in a typical youtube
video right um
the individual images in the frames
uh the the overall motion pattern across
the video the associated audio and any
speech that might be there uh in the
audio stream and use all of this to
recognize you know whether somebody is
baking a cake or is it a parkour video
or so on and so forth
so these were two
seemingly orthogonal problems but one of
the surprises i had working on these
projects was that you know i was able to
take the algorithms i
developed for
analyzing the images in aladdin right
on the youtube videos and apply the same
system
for the more higher level analysis that
mindset was
looking for and actually get very strong
results
and even more interestingly
uh you know again you know i told you i
was in a speech recognition team uh you
know very strong history in that but i
took these
relatively simplistic algorithms i was
using to analyze the images and i
applied it on the noisy web audio and it
was actually producing very strong
results so so it's pretty much the same
algorithmic core
to do high level vision
low level vision for the web videos as
well as analyzing noisy web audio wow
right
and you know these were all based on a
technique called bag of words uh that
has actually origins in natural language
processing um so the the one difference
is when you're looking at visual and
audio space you need to convert the
continuous signals to uh to learn the
words and you know again there is a
technique called vector quantization
that was first developed in uh speech
analysis that you use to learn the words
first and then you use the bag of word
representation to
uh apply a downstream classifier
right
and and in retrospect you know i didn't
recognize this at that time but all of
these results were pointing to some of
the largest trends in machine learning
in the last five to six years right um
including pre-training
reusing model architectures across
different tasks and modalities transfer
learning all of these things really took
off in the last years and and you know
now in retrospect you know the results i
was getting
was uh
actually showing
the the possibility there um you know i
must have didn't connect the dots
but
the overall research ecosystem that
projects like mindsey and aladdin funded
enabled the researchers to you know to
follow through on some of these and uh
you know uh make the uh breakthroughs
that they eventually did
so
um overall you know to me i think in
retrospect uh i think the visual
intelligence is to me it's basically a
collection of all of these insights
tricks hacks all of that that
these hands-on research surfaces
and enable modern cv uh
models to recognize diverse visual and
multimodal concepts at different levels
of abstraction and also you know there
is a increasing trend towards smaller
training data sets as well so all of
yeah all of this to me represents visual
intelligence rather than one
high-level philosophical concept
got it
uh
the problems that you're trying to solve
here
are just so incredibly interesting to
think about how we're trying to identify
and understand both what's happening in
a video but also as you mentioned this
um
you know this in this visual
intelligence uh being able to understand
what you're seeing
is uh
i mean this is something i've spent a
little bit of time reading about but
it's uh it's remarkable to hear about
the the ways that you're thinking about
solving this problem and the the efforts
that you go through with it it seems to
me like you've you've done quite a bit
of work in your history uh on video
analysis and event detection um
i would love to know i mean obviously
you're now working on the alexa team i
would love to know
kind of how you're applying all the
stuff that we've been talking about and
that you've learned over your history
how are you applying that to like
multi-modal alexa and the camera that we
have on the device and the interactions
that we have there
yeah
i'm i'm quite excited about the
technologies we have been working on
right you know that will further improve
uh the experience we are delivering to
our customers
so uh i can discuss a couple of examples
uh the first is natural turn taking
right um where we leverage visual and
audio cues to enable natural
wake word free interactions with alexa
so uh you know we have developed cv
based models to determine if a user is
looking at the device or not uh
similarly we have also developed audio
based models to recognize if an
utterance is directed at the device and
also reduce false wakes due to ambient
noise or alexa's own responses
and and finally we have also developed
fusion algorithms that combine all of
these cues and help alexa to sort
through utterances in a wakeword free
multi-party uh conversation um uh so you
know maybe you and your spouse are
talking to each other as well as alexa
to
um select a movie or something like that
um
so
uh how can alexa automatically sort
through all the utterances and identify
the ones that are directed to uh to the
device and respond only to
only to them
some of those features kind of
highlighted
when the when the echo show 10 was first
launched um i noticed in many ways the
the ways that we were showing that
device being used were
along those same lines right multiple
people standing around the kitchen
they're talking with each other but then
they direct something about hey tell me
about this movie or tell me this thing
and the device was able to recognize
when it should and shouldn't participate
i think that's a is that a reasonable
translation of what you're describing
absolutely that's exactly what we are
talking about right you know we
announced it uh in the devices event in
uh september 2020
um and you know we look forward to
offering this feature to customers
pretty soon
oh great
yeah
the the second uh um uh uh
thing i wanted to also uh
discuss in terms of what we are doing
uh in terms of adding multi-sensory
capabilities to alex is in augmenting
calls between alexa devices with visual
effects right you know these include
face stickers and style transfer um so
echo show and other screen devices have
played a major role in helping people
stay connected especially during the
pandemic you know i'm sure you have
heard
uh stories and and you know that is
something we all at alexa draw a lot of
energy and pride from yeah
so what we have done is you know we have
developed cv and graphics technology to
make calls with them even more
delightful right uh this includes
techniques that can be used to render
realistic face stickers like sunglasses
or hats hot dog graphics that cover the
whole body and such and we also develop
neural style transfer technology uh to
transform the scene in a call so in a
call like this
um you know
you can make them appear like they are
actually in a
street art or a classic painting and and
many more
um you know we have published some of
our work here as well you know in
addition to building the product we have
also been doing some cutting edge uh
research uh we have published our work
here at cvpr um
and you know several scientists in the
team have been inventing you know rex
and ios and several of those guys uh and
you know this was an oral presentation
in cvpr i don't know how much this means
to you or a lot of the audience today
but for a computer vision researcher
getting an overall presentation in cvpr
is like you know maybe winning the oscar
or something so oh my gosh i'm quite
proud of what we did there yeah that's
uh that's fantastic i was it was it was
interesting as you said that you're like
yeah we gave an oral presentation i was
like oh that's excellent good job uh i
didn't realize that that was uh that's a
major honor but i know a lot of the the
science
conferences oftentimes you are just
presenting a paper um an opportunity to
read and then do some q a
but it's not
you're not up on a stage describing your
work in detail
so that's uh that's fantastic
congratulations yeah thank you uh i mean
thanks to all my co-authors more than
myself here i thank you sure uh so
as we talk about multi-media processing
and some of the things you were
describing how are we using machine
learning to do that and are there any
issues that you confront in like
training and deploying some of those
models
yeah absolutely uh you know um as you
know
at amazon privacy is foundational to uh
how we go about our work right and our
cv models are no exception
um you know so
uh with that in mind we have developed
techniques such as you know synthetic
data generation to make our models
robust to a variety of camera angles and
lighting conditions
um further you know we do not collect
any image or video data from the
customers to train these models and have
placed significant emphasis on
developing on-device models as well
so
um yeah those are some
key things uh we have been looking at
cool
uh and i i think that's that's really
good to mention because i know a lot of
people are very aware of the fact that
we we do capture audio data to use to
train a lot of our models
um but that's not actually something
that i had heard described and it's
refreshing to hear that we're not
actually capturing
image or video data to do the same thing
um because obviously that does capture
photos and video of our individual
customers and users and uh without their
permission that seems like a massive
overreach so that's that's actually
fantastic news to hear that we're not
doing that absolutely
so we talked earlier about kind of the
natural turn tanking capabilities of
alexa and some of the things that you
had worked on
um
with this capability alexa is doing more
than just getting acoustic cues right uh
i would imagine there's some visual cues
that are mixed in as well to recognize
when someone is facing or addressing a
device
tell me more about that
yeah um so
a significant breakthrough we achieved
to enable natural turn taking is uh
developing a mission learning system
that can detect if an utterance is
directed at alexa right
without you having to say the wake word
right um so this sort of is our uh is
the next step we want to take in making
communication with device natural right
you know uh you know we we both have
been talking for for uh for quite a
while now
and uh you know i'm not calling you jeff
every time i'm talking to you right
right so that's sort of the uh insight
behind why we developed a system
and uh one of the challenge in
developing this technology was to
determine the target of a customer
utterance right um so say you and your
partner and alexa are in a multi-party
conversation and you say something like
you know how about watching a comedy
movie
um is that
targeted at alexa or are you talking to
your partner right uh that's a that's a
pretty hard problem to
uh uh solve for right
so we had to take steps to make the
system have also low latency so that we
can accurately detect the start of such
a device directed utterance and
ultimately uh we developed a system that
used you know both audio and visual cues
to determine when the speech is directed
to alexa
right um and and also you know as i
mentioned you know we have placed a lot
of emphasis on on-device models for our
cv technology
and uh that's true in natural return
taking as well we developed a compact
version of this model that
runs entirely on device with minimal
latency right um and to prevent false
wakes in the entity mode due to you know
ambient noise you know for example you
are looking at the device so in that
sense the cv model is telling that uh uh
there is somebody directed at the device
but maybe there is ambient noise or
somebody outside the scene is talking
that could be mistakenly interpreted as
a device directed utterance because i am
looking at the device so we developed uh
audio device voice activity detection
models
to identify these sorts of false wakes
and reduce them
uh you know again based on a model
called convolutional neural networks
that are also quite popular in cv
so in all of these cases
um we conducted extensive experiments
um uh you know like consistent with our
dive deep principles and inventing on
behalf of the customers um
so you know we developed something that
has minimal latency and uh
high performance in terms of detecting
these devices
there's two things that come out of that
um that are that i want to highlight the
first one that you mentioned was the the
idea that
we're starting to move things
as you mentioned with latency we're
starting to move things to operate
locally on a device which means that it
doesn't have to make that call out it
doesn't have to reach out to the cloud
to get a bunch of additional information
it's actually making its interpretation
there locally on the hardware
which obviously is a significant gain in
latency because you know calling out to
the internet can take
half to a couple of seconds
that's uh
well one that's remarkable and and
that's that's fantastic news uh the more
i think that we can do those kinds of
things
uh you know the better the experience
will be for all of our customers so
that's that's fantastic the the second
one
that you called out was
the idea of the combination of voice and
audio um gestures
gestures is probably the wrong word but
the the interaction between a a voice
and a face uh and the the video imagery
that you're getting
um
how far have we taken that i mean if if
i were to just turn to my device right
now the echo show 10 that i have behind
me and i put my face right in front of
it and i stare at it and i ask it a
question
my suspicion is that's not going to
respond to me
um not until i say the wake word
are there
are there specific rules that users have
to follow to get that kind of experience
or is this still research that we're
working on that is not
rolled out or maybe
as i mentioned earlier uh in the talk
you know we look forward to launching
these to our customers soon oh i see
um so
in terms of uh
uh
um
how this will be made available and such
uh you know we will definitely
communicate that
uh when we make the uh launch
announcements and such uh but but what i
do want to again re-emphasize
is the
uh significant invention
uh that we have made
in amazon's unique customer upset way
right
we have developed cutting edge on device
uh technology for processing both the
visual and audio signals
to enable liquid-free interactions
right
so
you know we look forward to
getting it in front of the customers and
uh
hear their feedback
learn from it and continuously improve
i look forward to that as well that's uh
those those are exciting
uh all right so we're gonna we're gonna
turn the subject a little bit uh to the
topic of few shot learning uh which i've
written a paper on recently
um i know very little about fushot
learning but
pretty much everything that i've asked
you about to this point um not only have
you given a fantastic explanation but
you've you've increased my knowledge and
understanding of these topics as well so
i'd love to know more about q shot
learning and kind of what this trend is
yeah uh so again you know i told you
earlier um i'm actually getting a lot of
energy working from working with various
scientists on the team
uh with various levels of experiences
right you know
i learn a lot from the senior vps i
learn a lot from scientists on the
ground and this is one of those examples
of the later right you know so uh this
was something i worked with my
co-author rakesh um and
it will be useful to set some context of
broader mission learning
trends and concepts so that you can
understand you know what he did here
so um uh you know let's take a simple
natural language processing uh task
right uh jeff is a principal evangelist
at uh alexa working for amazon right um
so there are various things that that
you're communicating in that sentence
that somebody might be interested in
right who are we talking about
um uh what are they what is their job
which company are their work are they
working for so on and so forth right so
there are various entities mentioned in
that utterance and to build a mission
learning model how do you go about it
you annotate
uh the person name is jeff the
job name is evangelist the
product name is alexa and the company
name is amazon right and you collect
tens of thousands of these samples maybe
hundreds of thousands and then uh
feed it to a machine learning model that
learns to recognize these entities from
an utterance right um now now let's take
a completely different task right uh
maybe you want to understand
automatically understand the sentiment
expressed in a movie review right uh you
know one person says about a movie uh
this movie
uh kept me engaged throughout and i came
uh excited came out excited after
watching it right that's a positive
review or somebody else says you know
this movie put me to sleep within the
five minutes and thankfully i didn't
wake up right uh that's a negative
review right
and now
to train a natural language processing
model for the second task you have to
again go and collect a whole bunch of
data
and train the model right
the first model you're trained to
recognize the named entities doesn't
quite translate to the second task
and you need to collect a lot of samples
so there's been a lot of excitement in
the machine learning community recently
around models like bert and gpt that you
might have heard
and what is happening there is something
called pre-training right
while task specific annotated data is
extremely expensive and hard to collect
there is a lot of
free text available all over the web
right
um
so is there a way
for you to use this large volume of data
to pre-train a model
and then
you can have some task-specific data
that you can fine-tune this pre-trained
model on right so that's a new paradigm
for training machine learning models
and for the pre-training what people do
is they come up with a you know token
task right um say say for example i told
you right you know jeff is an evangelist
working for alexa i randomly mask off a
few tokens right i drop the is
add and so on and so forth and say
can you can the model learn to predict
the
uh tokens i masked off
right or you can formulate it as a full
reconstruction problem you know i take a
utterance drop some tokens
and then
ask the model to reconstruct the full
sentence from the
sentence uh with the master tokens that
i gave so there are different kinds of
pre-training tasks you can come up with
to leverage this large volume of data
and
one thing we noticed
is that often people pre-trained the
model using one particular task right
like the mask filling task i described
or reconstruction
and then when they want to train a task
specific model like a question answering
system or such
they use a different
uh target from what they pre-trained to
fine-tune on the task-specific data set
right
so
what we showed is if you are able to
formulate the fine-tuning task
to be aligned with the task for which
you pre-trained
then we can actually get very
significant results
in the few short setting where you know
you only have a few examples right you
know the the sentiment recognition or
name identity retention tasks i
mentioned
if you have only 16 examples
of movie sentiment classification or 20
examples
for named entity recognition in an
utterance
how well can you take a pre-trained
model
and make it work on that task
right and you showed very significant
improvements uh on on you know uh the
the benchmark uh qa data sets in the
community uh for example a 34.2 percent
uh absolute f1 score improvement with
only 16 examples
and and what we also showed is
there's a trend towards training larger
and larger models in the community right
when bird was launched it had over 330
million parameters
today the larger model largest model in
existence that that people are published
about
is about
550 billion parameters right you know
that's how much people have increased
the size and what we showed is
first we can make the small models be
competitive with these large models that
are super expensive to train
and also the particular technique we
proposed to align the pre-training loss
function with the fine-tuning loss
function
uh continues to produce improvements
even as we go up the uh size of the
model
right so those are uh
two key things
uh we were able to show
very cool and so it seems to me like
pre-trained models are probably the the
potential future of a lot of this work
uh yeah in many ways it's it's it's the
present already right uh
the
bert models i i think it was uh
published in 2018 if i remember
correctly so it's just about three three
and a half years ago
but uh
in terms of the overall conscience
consciousness of the nlp community
um pretty much uh
most of the work from before is
superseded by these models these days
um and and uh definitely yeah it's it it
is uh it's good if it's not all of the
future it's going to be a very
significant chunk of the future
you had mentioned gpt is an example of
that um i think that's something that
probably most of our audience is at
least familiar with
gbc3 um
those those kinds of things are
just
it that kind of capability uh just
absolutely remarkable
uh to think about the fact that we can
consume so much of that
content that's available on the web and
use it in a way to generate
conversations and
intelligence yeah and and on gpt3 and
and you know uh that sort of thing there
is also another interesting you know i
was talking about uh supervised learning
right and then pre-training and
fine-tuning
and gpt-3 was one of the earliest
demonstrations of what's called
prompt-based learning
so
instead of giving samples and annotating
them and fine-tuning your model you can
just describe the task right and and
give a prompt and then the system can
automatically produce an answer right
it's not always perfect you know it's
still a work in progress
um but but the prompt-based learning
is also a huge breakthrough i think
that's
uh um
that i personally feel
non-machine learning folks might catch
on to faster than uh folks who are sort
of deep in machine learning and still
uh
uh working in the uh you know
pre-training fine-tuning or even
supervised training framework so yeah a
lot of exciting developments definitely
for sure um well so i was thinking we
were going to talk a little bit about
pre-trained models in the future but it
sounds to me like that's that's the
present if anything so i mean you've
been in this industry for a while 20
years or so
i'd love to know you know in in all the
advancements in machine learning and
computer vision and things that you've
seen over time
what do you think the big advancements
over the next 20 years are going to be
yeah um i think the
next major trend appears to be quite
consistent you know across all of the
ml areas right
some of the notable trends you know we
already touched upon right definitely
further development of on-device
processing
um the second is around data efficient
learning right few or even zero shot
uh synthetic data generation
um and also increasingly model
interpretability and uh privacy
preservation so
um
these are all in my opinion uh key
trends
um and and these are all not secrets too
right you know if you look at uh what
top
folks or practitioners in machine
learning are spending their time on uh
these are the kinds of problems uh
people are already spending their time
on
very cool
all right so i have a question that i
usually wrap uh wrap up as we use as we
talk with folks from our amazon science
organization
and for many of the people that are
watching this live or maybe watching
this as a recording later um i love to
give them any career guidance or advice
that you can offer
um if you think about a research career
at amazon what are some of the things
that you would offer to people that
might be considering joining us
yeah so uh i would probably uh structure
my answer into two parts right one is in
general you know if you are pursuing a
career in machine learning computer
vision and such uh how do you go about
it
and uh and all of them apply to a
scientist at amazon
and uh what are unique things about
amazon that
we definitely want to we are proud of
here and we want to communicate to
our audience right the first is you know
as we have been discussing so far a key
modeling techniques are starting to
converge across different tasks and
modalities
so i would definitely recommend
researchers to not restrict themselves
to any one modality and intentionally
explore across different tasks so that
they can surface novel insights and
bring those insights across many
problems
right
for example the pre-training and
transfer learning and all of these
things we discussed about in the context
of
language models
a lot of the initial compelling results
earlier in the 2010s were demonstrated
in computer vision
and uh people spent a few years to see
if the same thing can be done in natural
language crossing and bert sure indeed
the the results that people are seeing
in cv is also transferable to language
processing and now language processing
has really taken it to the next level
right so i would suggest that
intentional exploration across multiple
problem areas
the second thing i would say is you know
especially people with an academic
background there is a tendency to over
access over achieving state-of-the-art
results on some benchmark data sets
right
these data sets are absolutely helpful
for the community to make progress
but small improvements in such data sets
may not have a lot of real world value
so i would recommend scientists to also
develop strong experimental discipline
and get the basics right you know for
example are you clearly partitioning
your data into train dev and test sets
uh be sure you're not tuning hyper
parameters on your final test sets
because that will give you misleadingly
good results
um and also how often are you measuring
performance on the test set right the
more you do
the less valuable the gains you are you
see are because you as a human are
already learning things about the data
set by running experiments on those test
sets sure and also
uh how are you optimizing for hyper
parameters you know for folks in machine
learning they know what i'm talking
about and how sensitive is your model to
them you know if you change the hyper
parameter from 0.1 to 0.15 suddenly the
performance drops by 10 percent maybe
your 0.1 result is also not very
credible then right um and uh
um most tasks in computer vision all of
these do need deep learning models but
many real world data analysis problems
do not so take a hard look and see if
your implementations can be simplified
and then
be sure you are also able to communicate
the simplifying effect that ml solutions
have to other stakeholders like you know
engineers or product managers right
because i also hear that you know folks
typically dive too much into the
mathematical details when they're
talking to people outside their field
and
those other stakeholders often
think that machine learning is too
complex
and they end up accumulating a
collection of rules and hacks in the
production system
because they offer the shortest path but
in reality a well-defined machine
learning model can eliminate a lot of
engineering complexity development and
maintenance time that a scientist should
communicate and get buy-in from their
stakeholders from right here's a general
advice
sorry i think that makes sense because a
lot of
what i enjoy doing in having these
interviews is being able to take kind of
the i mean you went very deep with us on
a few things you were talking about
specific parameters and and values for
uh training your models
i like to think that my job sometimes is
to ask those kind of almost naive
questions that are well how does this
actually apply to the real world or how
do we use this thing or how does that
stuff uh come across and i think that's
really good advice for anybody that's
thinking about being a scientist at
amazon is that you you need to be able
to talk like a scientist to other
scientists but you also need to be able
to translate that down to a
much more understandable format for
those that aren't yeah absolutely so
like you know we talked about
pre-trained transformer models right you
know if i say bert is using
self-attention
to pre-train on the mc4 corpus or
something like that uh that means
nothing to you but if i say that it
offers a way to leverage unannotated web
data which can then be used for your
natural language processing tasks with
the smallest amount of training examples
needed
that has value right you know i don't
have to undertake a lot of data that
saves me money and it's going to improve
my performance on the task i'm
interested in so i want to learn more
about bird right that's how a
stakeholder will
respond right
um so that's one but that's also giving
me a good segue right you know at amazon
we are fundamentally a customer focused
company right
at the company level of course we are
focused on the end customers but
internally at amazon
also you know sometimes our customers
are other partner teams and we always
want to identify who our customer is and
work backwards from their use cases and
develop technology
that helps
achieve an impact for our customers so i
would advise researchers at amazon to
always be aware of the problem you're
addressing
irrespective of how you deep go into any
specific algorithm or modeling approach
right always remember the problem don't
get lost in the
beauty of the models you're looking at
right secondly uh scientists at amazon
are deeply integrated into teams with
stakeholders from diverse backgrounds
including engineers program and product
managers right
it's not a
separated research organization such you
know you are working with
folks from other backgrounds so
definitely scientists should be able to
work with all of them and be able to
deliver results uh finally at amazon you
know we work on some of the most diverse
and complex issues and projects across
all areas of computer science machine
learning and computer vision right we
have real projects with real customers
across the board in our initiatives and
we strive to delight them
so if all of this excites you you know
come join us uh we look forward to you
uh working with uh with you
agree thank you uh i want to thank you
for joining us today this has been an
enlightening conversation i certainly
learned a lot and i hope that our
audience did as well
for uh for those of you that are
watching check out amazon.science the
website where you can find a host of
published papers and blog posts where
we've been uh talking about a lot of
those things during this session i'd
also encourage you to check out the em
nlp 2021 page
which gives you the opportunity to view
all of the accepted research papers at
this year's conference the content
should give you more of a flavor of the
kind of work we do here at alexa ai and
you can always go to amazon.science to
get the latest on the new research
techniques and published work from
across our amazon science teams
including the work that pradeep is uh
participating in
so uh pretty i do want to thank you one
more time uh before we sign off here i'm
gonna show a quick video that gives some
people this is a new one we've never
shown before
but give some people some insight on
what it's like to work on the amazon
science team
[Music]
[Music]
the first word that comes to my mind
when i think about the culture
in alexa is exciting
i constantly feel that i'm on the edge
of the doable
that i'm breaking new ground
that i'm creating new things
it's an environment of invention
of builders of questioning what you've
done
we definitely do hire people from a
diverse set of backgrounds we need a lot
of different skill sets
to make it work we need all those
viewpoints even though it's been in the
market for for
many years now
there's still like a lot of work to be
done and as you see like there are like
new devices coming every whatever every
month or so each of those have different
capabilities and different challenges so
basically that means that there's like a
constant flow of like new problems to
solve so like it's never really done in
that sense
what it can do the future is even more
exciting than what it has already done
and to me that's the definition of a
field that is still in its infancy
people who come to amazon will be
looking at fundamental questions of what
it means to be human what it means to be
interacting with a machine and we'll be
solving fundamental problems at amazon
everything starts with understanding who
your customer is and what they need
and working backwards from that into
what it is that you actually need to
build
in my experience it's been really
exciting to be able to work on on
science projects there are these great
science mentors there's even this amazon
scholars program where there are
professors who split some of their time
between university and amazon and i've
been able to work with one the first
thing i would tell anyone considering a
role in alexa ai is
get into alexa ai as quickly as you can
it's a super exciting place to be and if
you want to do research in ai and if you
want to connect that research into
tangible real world impact this is the
place to do it